you have more characters than most
comedic performers I know you you come
up terrified to be myself really don't
like to be a minute I'm just curious
your character sir I mean when you've
been in comedy a long time you feel like
you've seen it all and I will say this
about you when you come up with
characters I haven't I always think how
did he come up with that guy oh how did
you come up they're very they're quite
unusual they're quite strange yeah where
do you get your ideas for these people I
come up with them in different ways I
have a character a popular character
named Jerry O'Hearn who's like this
stand-up comic and the way that came
about is I used to just amuse myself on
the subway riding in from Brooklyn to
Manhattan with a friend and I would just
kind of try to go as long as I could
talking without saying anything like see
if I can get all the way from deep
Brooklyn into Manhattan without saying
it so I would just go well you know it's
interesting I mean here we are we're
sitting here and I don't know I mean for
one thing I mean you got to consider it
from all angles I mean I don't know and
after all I mean it's after I'm you know
what I don't care for that but from
another perspective you can see the
other way and just kind of how long
could I go say that there's no content
whatsoever but it all sounds kind of
alright all sounds like words and
somebody overhearing it for a while
wouldn't realize I haven't said anything
right right just see how long I could do
it and then I was asked to do like a
late stand-up show and I didn't have
anything to do so I said well maybe that
could be a character so I was introduced
as a stand-up and I just came out and
said you know all this stuff that's
going on in the world today I mean you
got to be kidding me I mean you got guys
over here going hey look at this and
guys over here go and check it out and
I'm here in the middle go WOW nobody
told me that toe is gonna be in sign off
on that you gotta be kidding me
unbelievable hey I don't know what all
this cost you a certain amount of money
do a little crowd work
don't get mad don't get mad now yeah
here's my impression of this guy getting
ready to come here tonight how about
this okay is that I bet you can kind of
get away with doing that I bet they're
people that are like that's guys good
right he tells it like it is this place
is interesting this is like somebody
said hey let's right this way to see if
it works
nothing with a stick there's nothing in
there what about this guy
don dimelo I'm kind of fascinated by
that here is that there's a picture of
Don Knotts a Photoshop job that's not my
torso I have a normal body yeah but John
D'Mello is probably my most popular
character in a sign of the moral decay I
think because he's how this came about
was I saw an ad for the Radio City Music
Hall
Christmas Spectacular which is like
there's a live baby and camels and like
a live nativity scene and then there's
Santa Claus and then there's these
there's the these leggy dancers you know
the rocket Rockettes
yeah and it just seemed odd to me what
is that doing in a children's show why
is there this holdover from the Ziegfeld
Follies in the Moulin Rouge these women
you know like dancing across the stage
doing the can-can it just seems odd yeah
to me so I thought I decided to create
the character of the guy who's in charge
of that and he's just this don dimelo
theatrical director and I keep those
girls nice in the legs nice in the body
that's a little something for daddy
that's just soldier suit and get out
there and dance across the stage I got
it
I got a hooked on heroin they'll do
anything you tell I keep them in a pen
backstage box
you're gonna be sued by the estate of
burgess Meredith chase after the
chickens girls hey thanks for watching
be sure to click subscribe to see even
more great Conan clips you may now
return to your pirated movies and creepy
Japanese pornography